preview
whenever you return to an older game
it's a crapshoot as to whether it'll be
as good as you remember or whether
you'll discover that a game you once
loved just isn't fun anymore thankfully
fable anniversary won't be ruining any
memories this visually buffed re-release
retains the charm and body spirit that
made the original fable so delightful as
a remaster fable anniversary is one of
the better ones should you compare the
original and the new release
side-by-side you immediately see the
differences this isn't a case of the
resolution being cranked up but entire
assets being recreated including
architecture and character models the
lighting too has been adjusted to
reflect real-time sun rays and other
natural elements though this change dims
some of the ambient visual glow that
makes the world of Albion so warm and
inviting if you never played the
original you're probably more concerned
with fable anniversaries own unique
merits and there are many as the unnamed
hero of Albion you galavant about it's
charming towns and meadows performing
quests that have you protecting citizens
from bandits and infiltrating prisons
but childhood precedes heroism and the
first hour or so of the game chronicles
the events that scarred you in your
youth while simultaneously serving as an
extended tutorial your interactions with
the populace aren't limited to the kind
involving a bow or a sword you express
your innermost self not with what you
say but with what you do prove your
strength by flexing your muscles prove
your cruelty by murdering an old friend
in front of hundreds of onlookers how
you act is reflected in how others
perceive you and in how you look
bystanders clap as you pass by if they
like you and you sprout devil horns or
develop a halo depending on how
good or evil you are it's a shame the
world design doesn't reflect the
openness of Fable anniversary's social
structure even in 2004 fables segmented
kingdom was confining now treading
relatively narrow paths only to reach a
loading screen every few minutes is even
less satisfying
it'll cost you to get through when you
aren't busy voguing in front of
impressed onlookers you're beating up on
baal verrines and trolls using a
combination of melee weapons bows and
magic spells the magical possibilities
are the most intriguing given how they
allow you to summon a ring of flames or
call forth the trio of sentient swords
to give you a hand in battle putting
those disciplines into practice can be
frustrating however the originals
targeting system wasn't great and while
fable anniversary represents some
improvement it's not much of one
luckily fable anniversary is an easy
game so these kinds of foibles are
nuisances not rage inducing frustrations
it's also a game about discovery more so
than you might imagine for one that
confines you to such constricted
passages inspecting various nooks
reveals treasure chests and talking
diamond doors scattered about the land
have secrets locked behind them but you
must meet certain requirements before
they swing open those doors are
delightful conversationalist and are
part of the genial attitude that makes
fable fun to play its combat and world
design have aged but fable anniversaries
too charismatic to stay mad at for long
you old choices
whether they lead you down the path of
good or evil will change the face of the
world
[Music]